The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SARA VERILLI: OK.
So I get to do the introduction
spiel for today's class.
I'm going to start by
just saying what we're
doing in class
today, so you've got
sort of a framework of what
we're doing, because we're
doing a whole lot of things.
And we're going to be
jumping between speakers,
and workshops, and
lectures, and in class work.
So we actually
have a lot of stuff
to try and get
through today to get
you guys started on Project 1.
So we're going to
introduce Project 1.
And that's actually
what my brief lecture's
going to be after I get
done with the class spiel.
We're going to hear lectures
on how to do brainstorming.
And then we'll ask
you to brainstorm.
We're going to do
lectures on prototyping.
And then I'm going to give
a more pointed lecture
on what we mean by
low-fidelity prototype, which
is what Project 1 calls for.
And we are going to
do all those bits
of in-class work, hopefully,
scattered along the way.
OK.
So moving on to introducing
Project 1, so that you've got--
and the reason we're
introducing Project 1 before we
give the supporting
lectures is so you've
got something to frame.
You're going to be hearing
lectures about prototyping
and brainstorming, which we
want you to do in Project 1.
We want you to be
thinking about the project
as we give you the lecture,
so you can try and figure out
how you're going to be applying
that information to the thing
we're going to be asking
you to be doing, OK?
So the overall goal is-- and
I have to actually stand back
so I can either see my notes,
or I can see the slides.
But I can't see both--
to demonstrate a working
mechanic via a low-fidelity
paper prototype,
to service the prototype
for a digital game
while tracking and understanding
how your game design changes
over time.
Any words there you
didn't understand?
Because we've got
a lot of jargon,
actually, up there, a lot of
game design jargon up there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SARA VERRILLI: OK.
AUDIENCE: What is
actually a mechanic?
SARA VERRILLI: A mechanic?
That's actually a
really good question.
A mechanic is
usually a key chunk
of a game by which
the player takes
actions in the game or
the game takes actions.
So if you're playing like a
basic platforming digital game,
one of your basic mechanics
is your character can jump.
And that's what your
character often uses
to solve a lot of problems.
A very common mechanic
in games is shooting.
So a mechanic is basically
an in-game action.
It's a game design
term for that.
Any other questions?
OK then.
So we're hoping that
this project will
teach you to do
prototyping, which
is a skill we will hope you will
use again in Projects 3 and 4,
and we expect you to.
And we're also
going to introduce
our very first project
management tool, which
is the design change log, which
is, hopefully, a reasonably
quick and concise way to record
the changes your team makes
to your design as your design
evolves and helps you keep
a group memory of
what you've done,
so you don't end up doing
the same things again.
But that's not actually
all we're hoping to do.
That's just the official goals.
We're also using it to
give you a small group
experience working in teams
on a creative project.
This is the first
and last time you'll
be in nice, small, tight
teams of three people.
Project 2, we boost you all
the way up to six people.
And by the end, we're going
to be in eight-person teams.
And you're going to get to
see just how more complex
it gets working with
bigger and bigger groups.
But we're going to start you
small for your first project,
so you get a chance to
learn how to communicate.
We're going to
teach brainstorming.
We're going to expect you to
brainstorm again for Projects 3
and 4, although we're not going
to formally tell you where
to do it or when to do it.
We're just going
to expect you, when
you form your groups, to
start going over ideas
to use the techniques we've
taught you in this project
to do that on your own.
We're also going to
teach you-- and I
think the most important
thing here is-- working fast.
You've got one week
to do this project.
The final version and your
project reports on this
are due next Monday.
You're going to get
some time in class.
But unfortunately,
we have a lot to say,
to teach you everything you
want to do in this class.
So you're not going
to get all of class.
You're going to get a
small portion of class
Monday and Wednesday.
And we're going to expect you
to be able to play something
on Wednesday in class.
Or hopefully, you'll
be running play tests.
We expect you to have
something working.
So you're going to have
to learn how to work fast.
How do you get those ideas
out of your head, onto paper,
and usable quickly?
And finally, the prototypes
you're using here
are going to move on to Project
2, probably about half of them.
Your team sizes are
going to be shrinking,
so we'll be doing fewer of them.
We, the instructors,
are going to take a look
at the prototypes
as they come in,
both during the
presentations and
during the playable
playtesting sessions.
And we're going to decide
which of those projects
we think really do
have the potential
to go on to be Project 2.
If your prototype
isn't chosen to go on,
that doesn't mean it's
not a good prototype.
We may choose to exclude
things because we think
the scope is too big
for a two-week project,
we think it's a
little too complicated
to try and
communicate the ideas.
We may also think that there
are other projects that sort of
nailed the requirements better.
So your prototype hasn't
failed if it doesn't move on,
it's just that there were
other ones that we think
fit all the constraints better.
And all the prototypes
are important to do.
All right.
So that's that.
OK.
So the breakdown of the
project is, today, we'll
be forming teams,
doing brainstorming,
and getting started
working on things.
We will do the first
formal playtesting
session on Wednesday, Monday,
everything gets turned in,
and including your change
log and a presentation.
The vision document, we
will be making in class.
So don't worry about
that, because we'll
be explaining what
a vision document is
and how you make one in class.
So don't worry too much about
that particular requirement.
The presentation,
the one-minute pitch,
will be one of the things that
helps sell your classmates
on joining your team and
will be one of the things
that we use to
decide whether or not
we think you guys have
a good enough core
idea and enough core excitement
to move that prototype forward.
So it's actually
pretty important.
And remember, it needs
to be one minute.
We're going to have like
10 groups up pitching,
so it's going to
have to be fast.
Finally, design change
logs, which some of you
may never have heard about.
Whoa.
Oh, no.
My slide, it isn't there.
PHILLIP TAN: Oh.
Because that
screen's [INAUDIBLE].
SARA VERRILLI: Because
this one isn't-- aha.
Oh, boy.
PHILLIP TAN: Let me
restart this presentation.
SARA VERRILLI: So
who here has used
a design change log before?
Because if you've taken
608, I know you have.
All right.
So those are your experts.
If you have one of those
people on your team,
you're in good shape.
Talk to them.
But essentially, what
a design change log is,
it's actually really simple.
It's a table, three columns.
You've got a date.
You've got some action
you made on your design
to change it in some
way, and then you've
got the reason why
you made the change.
And every time you make
a significant change
to your project, and/or every
day you work on your project,
you make another entry so
that your team and the people
working on it and the people
looking at your project
to see where it is now can see
why you made the decisions you
made and what
decisions you made,
what features you dropped,
what features you added,
what problems you
were trying to solve
when you made those changes.
Yeah.
I was probably-- anyway.
So that is, in fact,
a design change log.
There's an example of one at
the bottom of the Problem 1
handout of the-- there's an
example of one at the Project 1
handout, so you can
see an example there.
Are there any questions?
Hearing no takers, I
hand you over to Phillip
for brainstorming.
PHILLIP TAN: OK.
All right, let's talk
about brainstorming.
How many of you have done
brainstorming in any class?
High school?
Before high school?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: Wow.
OK.
All right.
So it's a term that gets
bandied around a lot.
Let me see.
Awesome.
However, there is a
problem with brainstorming.
And a lot of people
have practiced it
without actually knowing
why certain things are
done in a certain way
and, as a result of that,
may actually be
doing it incorrectly.
We have an excerpt
of an article--
I'm sorry-- a chapter
from a book called,
Applied Imagination, which
is written by Alex Osborn.
This is a guy who
actually came out
with the term brainstorming
and the practice of it.
He worked in advertising.
And he has lamented
since he wrote that book
that a lot of
people kind of liked
the output of brainstorming,
but didn't really understand
the practice of it.
So I'm going to try to
start from first principles
so that you understand
why brainstorming is
and how it's supposed
to be working.
And hopefully, you can sort
of get the benefits of it,
without maybe, say,
overstating its power.
Now, the main reason why we're
doing brainstorming in groups--
you will hear people out there
in the game industry saying
that brainstorming's
not necessarily always
the best way to be able to come
up with an idea for a game.
However, in this
class in particular
and in a lot of video game
design outside of this class,
game design is coordinated,
creative collaboration
involving different
skilled workers.
And if this is going to
be the first time you're
going to work with
a team, you need
to understand who are the people
who you might be working with.
Brainstorming, if nothing else,
can be a really, really good
way to just be able to get a
sense of who it is that you're
going to be working with.
And when we start
forming up teams,
you're not going
to necessarily be
able to choose who you're
brainstorming with.
So you want to be able to get
a quick read of their ideas
and what their interests
are and maybe decide,
hey, this is a person I'm going
to do Project 1 with later on.
However, there are very
strong social pressures
of being imaginative in a
collaborative environment,
especially here in MIT.
There's a lot of pressure
to hold back your ideas
or maybe not say what's
coming to your mind
because you think
that's kind of dumb,
but other people are going
to think that I'm stupid,
or anything like that.
And brainstorming
has certain practices
to be able to get you past that.
So there are four
principles of brainstorming.
The [INAUDIBLE]
just do this thing.
This was the four principles
laid out by Alex Osbourne.
And he was Advertising Manager
at BBDO, which is a very, very
large advertising agency.
And there are certain
similarities at marketing
and video game design, right?
You can produce ads, you
can produce marketing,
you can produce games,
without necessarily saying,
yes, we solved the problem.
There's a lot of
different solutions
for exactly the same problem.
And advertising is trying to
get people to pay attention
to the ad, and maybe
you'll buy stuff.
In video games, it's
trying to create
an entertaining experience
for somebody else.
Millions of ways to be
able to accomplish that.
So we're not looking for
like, here's a engineering
solution to a engineering
problem where it does,
you know, if the
thing doesn't explode,
you know you've done a good job.
That's sort of like a very easy
metric to be able to measure
success.
For games, for
advertising, not so easy.
So here's the first
principle, no criticism.
How many of you have been
in a brainstorming session
where you said your idea,
and then somebody said, oh.
Yeah, OK.
All right.
I see some hands go up.
OK.
So this is the
most important rule
of a brainstorming session.
If you do not
stick to this rule,
if everybody around the group
doesn't stick to this rule,
you can ruin the entire session.
The whole session can
just become worthless.
You can give positive feedback
that says, thanks for the idea.
Just simply writing it down
is positive feedback of we've
received your idea.
But you want to hold back on
adverse judgment or any kind
of negative reinforcement.
You can share that after
the brainstorm session.
You just don't want to do that
during a brainstorm session,
because it inhibits the
process of creating new ideas.
Again, that's sort of
like professional shame,
especially in a place like
MIT, but also if you go out
into the corporate
world, this idea of you
don't want to look bad.
And then you can't
have that in your head
to have a proper
brainstorming session.
If you're worried about how your
ideas are going to be taken,
then you're not actually
generating ideas at the speed
that you need to be.
So you need to be able to
let your entire group know
that we now have total freedom
to explore all territories.
Whatever idea you generate,
we're going to write down.
And then we'll figure out which
are the good ideas after we've
generated all of these ideas.
Secondly, you kind of
want to be freewheeling.
Typically, the crazier
the idea, the better.
It's easier to be able
to tame down a crazy idea
than to take a fairly
unambitious idea
and scale it up.
So typically, you will
get your best ideas
from some sort of pipe
dream or blue moon
idea, something
that's out of scope,
something that's unfeasible.
And then you sort
of scale it down
into the thing that
is actually feasible.
So go ahead and
shoot for the moon.
Shoot for the game
that you can't possibly
develop in the next week or
in the next couple of weeks.
And then, after the
brainstorming session,
figure out how you're
going to pare down
that idea into something
that you can do in a week
or in two weeks.
Now you can expand
on simple ideas.
And I'll talk a little bit about
some strategies on doing that.
But usually, reworking a
wild idea to become feasible,
there's usually a
nugget there that's
a lot easier to identify
when you start big
and then shrink down.
What are you going for?
You're trying to come up with
as many ideas as possible.
Quantity.
The greater number of
ideas, the more likelihood
that some of those ideas are
actually going to be useful.
You're not actually
trying to solve
the problem in brainstorming.
Say, if the problem that
we're asking you to solve
is create something
playable in a week,
we're not asking you
to solve that problem
during the brainstorm session.
That comes after the
brainstorm session.
That comes with things
like prototyping,
which we'll get to later today.
Now, that's a simple
metric that you
can use to gauge the success
of a brainstorm session,
how many ideas that you
generate, at what pace
are you generating them at.
Again, that's why you don't
want to be judging ideas
while they're being generated.
All ideas should be included.
Nothing is excluded.
And you're going to
need to reinforce that
within the group of people
that you're brainstorming with.
There's somebody who's
actually got a job
to specifically do that, but
you've got to help with that.
And you can build on ideas.
You can refer back to ideas that
have already been mentioned.
Take the notes off,
and then combine them
with your own idea, even
if ideas that other people
have come up with, to be able
to come up with something
synthetically more complex.
Great ideas are
often generated when
disparate ideas are
combined, LEGO plus Star Wars
equals LEGO Star Wars.
[LAUGHTER]
Which is awesome, you know?
Marvel plus Capcom,
Marvel vs. Capcom.
OK, great ideas there.
And often, that's actually where
a lot of your really good ideas
are going to come
from, because you're
going to come up with a whole
bunch of really mundane things
that basically refer back
to games that you've already
played or ideas
that a lot of people
have encountered, but maybe
not encountered together
in the same context.
So this is how you're
going to do it.
You're going to start
off with a really,
really-- try to create
a little casual spirit.
This is not like a really
straight laced, formal affair.
Start with giving your
worst idea, the worst
idea that you can possibly think
of, the most useless, terrible.
If you have to do
offensive, sure,
but usually there's just an
idea that you know is dumb.
Just tell people that.
Everyone put it down.
Write it down.
While someone is speaking,
don't interrupt them.
But do designate a
facilitator at the beginning
of the session.
And it's going to
be that person's job
to keep things moving.
So you don't really
need to explain
so much, because again,
you're not trying
to solve the problem here.
You're just trying to be
able to get enough ideas out
so that whoever's performing
the role of the secretary
can write it down.
And again, before you
start the entire session,
make sure everybody
understands this process.
If there's somebody who
walked in late in the class
or something and is
just joining your team,
make sure they understand all
of these rules, these four rules
that I went through.
And write down everything.
Now, don't just write down
the title of the idea--
turtle tower defense,
I don't know--
those are three easy
words to write down,
but it might be difficult
for you to then remember
exactly what that
idea-- were they
like anthropomorphic turtles?
Are the turtles the towers?
Are the turtles
marching into towers?
You know, it's like,
what was that again?
Let whoever is taking down
notes take a little bit
more information, maybe
like a line of information,
just so that, when you
come back to that idea,
you don't look at a title
as, that looks like a--
what was that idea again?
Does anybody remember
what his idea was?
Just take the time to be
able to write things down.
Now, this is more general.
Today, we're asking
you very specifically
to brainstorm about
the game that you're
going to be prototyping
for Project 1.
But in general, you
can apply brainstorming
to a bunch of
different ideas, even
in the middle of a
project, Project 1 or later
or to other domains.
But it's very, very
important to be
able to know what
kinds of problems
are good for brainstorming
and what kinds of problems
are terrible for brainstorming.
You need to be able
to find a problem that
is very clearly defined.
The problem should be simple.
If you've got a problem
that's really, really
complex with lots of very
different opposing factors
that you have to be taking into
account, optimize, something,
you can either try to divide
those complex problems
into subdivisions where each
one of those subdivisions
could have a separate
answer, or you
could try to use a different
problem solving strategy
entirely.
You don't necessarily
need to apply
brainstorming to everything.
You should be able to articulate
the problem simply and clearly.
But just because I can
articulate the problem
doesn't necessarily
mean that it's
appropriate for brainstorming.
Osborn, for instance, gives
you an example of get married.
That's your problem.
All right.
OK.
And then you're
trying to solve that.
Brainstorming's a really
terrible technique for that.
Here are all the ways
that you can get married.
It's like that doesn't help.
Maybe that doesn't identify
the problem in the first place.
It's is a complex problem
that's a little bit too large.
What's your game
going to be about?
Or what is your player
going to do 80% of the time?
What's the one action
that your player
is going to do 80% of the time.
Where is our game set?
Who is our main character?
These are sort of
well-articulated problems
that brainstorming
does work for.
Now, responsibilities.
Again, I said designate
someone to be a facilitator.
And this person's job
is to basically keep
this whole session moving.
We don't like to use
the word "leader,"
because their job is not to be
the head of the brainstorming
session.
Your job is to facilitate it,
is to be the clerical equivalent
of moving the process along.
So you need to
understand the problem
and then make sure that
everybody around the brainstorm
group also understands
this problem.
And then, when the session
actually goes, every time, you
sort of sense that there's
some criticism coming out,
and you say, all right, we'll
put that aside and move on
to the next idea.
Try to defuse any criticism
when you see it coming.
And encourage people who
aren't speaking up to speak up.
Just simply, it's like
what's on your mind?
Or you'll call
out someone's name
and just say, any of these
things give you any ideas?
Try to sort of call
out those people who
aren't already
very much involved
in the process to try to
get them into the process.
Because the more people
riff off each other,
the more ideas you're going
to be able to generate.
Encourage people to
join ideas together.
Sometimes, you'll
just do that yourself,
just like look at
two random things
that you wrote down and just
try to slam them together,
just to get the process started.
And maybe other people will
do more logical compositions.
Make sure that no voices
are lost in this process.
It's not the facilitator's
job, by the way,
to identify what's the
best solution on the board
or on the computer when you're
taking down these ideas.
That may not actually be the
job of brainstorming at all.
That's actually a
problem that you
come to later when you see
the whole pile of ideas
that you generated.
And now, you figure
out what it is
that you're going to
choose for, say, Project 1.
Now, there's a second
person who's involved.
This is the person who either
has a giant Post-it pad,
or a chalkboard, or a
computer usually connected
to a projector.
And that person is the
secretary whose basic job
is to record every
single idea in a way
that everybody around the group
can actually see those ideas.
You don't want to just work
on your own personal laptop,
on your own screen where
no one else can see it,
because then other
people can't, say,
look at ideas that have
been mentioned before
and combine them.
So make sure that you're
writing things up on somewhere
where everyone can see.
We've got some giant
Post-it pads right here.
And you can grab them.
And we've got some markers.
Stick them up on the
wall and write on them.
So you want to
try to just report
on what people are saying.
Don't try to be
editorial about it.
Don't say, good idea, bad idea.
That's your job either.
You do want to keep
an eye on the time,
especially because we're
doing this in class and time
will run out.
So make sure that you
actually have enough time
to get down the to those
last couple of ideas
before we go into our next
part of our class, which
I think is prototyping.
The secretary can participate
in a brainstorming.
It's sometimes a
little bit tough.
It's tough to write
down and listen
to what other people
are saying while trying
to generate your own ideas.
So what you might want to do
is split up your brainstorming
session into,
basically, two halves.
How much time are we giving
them for brainstorming?
PROFESSOR: 30.
PHILLIP TAN: 30 minutes?
So split it into like
two 15-minute chunks.
And either the facilitator
and the secretary
can switch, or just
get two other people
to be secretary and facilitator.
So the people who were
facilitator and secretary
can sit down and have the space
to generate their own ideas
while someone else is
taking notes and making
sure the process is running.
So that's what we're
asking you to do.
Any questions about
brainstorming?
Or anything else I've said?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Is there a limit
or a minimum number of ideas
we have to come up with?
PHILLIP TAN: Is there
a minimum of ideas?
No.
In fact, that's probably
counterproductive.
Don't say, oh, we have to hit
a least 30, no-- it's 30 ideas
and we're done-- because
that implies that once you're
over 30, you can stop.
You don't want to stop.
You want to keep
generating ideas
until you run out of time.
And if it takes you 30 minutes
to come up with two ideas,
that's fine.
That's the group.
That's what your group
was able to come up with.
Generally, you want
to be generating
like a lot, several dozen
ideas in a 30-minute session.
SARA VERRILLI: I'm
going to ask you
to form groups of six people.
Grab the people who
are nearest you.
These groups of six are
going to like-- do us
a favor and everybody stand up.
As you form groups, sit down.
You've got three
minutes to form groups.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PHILLIP TAN: So we just finished
the brainstorming session,
and I'd like to get some
people's impression about what
worked.
Do you need some
time to get started?
Were people kind
of feeling it went
a little slowly at the beginning
and then picked up or died off
halfway?
Tell me some results.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
like the sessions were
like, instead of two-minute,
three-minute sessions,
they were like even shorter.
And like broken up into kind
of a mini theme [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: And it felt
like it ran out of steam.
PHILLIP TAN: OK.
All right.
So sort of like
breaking up even further
into smaller chunks and that.
OK.
Sure.
That's a good idea.
How about the note-taker as
a facilitator [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I think starting
with words and themes helped
us get just basic concepts
out there and then sort
of applying them, rather
than jumping into game ideas.
PHILLIP TAN: Right.
And one of the
reasons why we did
that will also give you an idea
of what's a theme versus whats
a mechanic, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It gets hard to
avoid the scenario of someone
writing an idea,
and then everyone's
like, oh, that's cool.
Let's talk more
about that thing,
instead of just throwing out
completely different ideas.
PHILLIP TAN: Right.
Oh, so switching to a
different idea, right?
Oh, you know, that's
not necessarily
a failure of the process either.
But you're right.
You're trying to
generate quantity.
And instead, people
trying to improve
the quality of the idea.
So yeah, but still that's a
happy problem to have, right?
It is a good point.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think, for our
team, jokes helped us a lot.
PHILLIP TAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Our first
situation was more tense.
And then, after one
or two specific ideas,
everyone became more casual
in saying more ideas.
PHILLIP TAN: And that's why the
throwing out the bad ideas part
helps as well.
It helps you get into that
mood of we can be silly now.
Something that might help with
the switching gears problem is
the act of writing it down, to
begin with, of course, sort of
says the idea is on record.
And you can always say,
let's get back to that later,
because you will get
back to it later anyway.
And there will be time
for that discussion.
It doesn't always work,
but it's worth a shot.
Cool.
OK.
Let's talk a little bit
again about Project 1,
just as a reminder.
There is a theme for
Project 1, and that's
planning for randomness.
You generated a lot of ideas.
We didn't really over-emphasize
that constraint right
at the beginning of
the brainstorm session,
because we wanted
you to generate
tons and tons of ideas.
But now, you should be looking
at that theme and the ideas
that you've generated
and figuring out
which ones of those kind
of match that theme.
Now, that's sort of
your overall constraint,
over-constraint of what we
want the players to be doing
is planning for randomness.
But is it in space?
Is it some sort of like
dice rolling mechanic?
Is it some sort
of race mechanic,
are just a branching decision
tree or something like that?
That comes into
themes and mechanics.
So you want to be
identifying that,
as well, as part of Project 1.
So what I'm going to be
asking you right now is that,
from your
brainstorming group, we
want you to split
into two groups.
That's your prototyping
group for Project 1.
You only have to work with this
group for one week, you know?
This is not a
long-term commitment.
And there were eight
brainstorming groups,
so basically, we're
looking for 16 teams.
And so we're
encouraging everyone
to be in groups of three.
Not only does that
mean that we will
get the right number
of groups, it also
means that if somebody
falls sick in the next week,
your team still has at least
two people to work on it.
So for each group of
three, first of all,
you figure out who you're
going to work with.
And then you choose one
item from your list, one
of these ideas from your
list, keeping in mind
those constraints
that I just mentioned.
And we will be using that idea
for the upcoming prototyping
workshop, which I
will be leading.
So once you know
what your idea is,
you know who you're
working with,
I will go into the
prototyping workshop
to tell you what you do next.
And the goal will
be to then test
that idea through the
process of prototyping.
And if it doesn't work,
you are free to choose
a different theme.
But you still have to
stick with your team.
OK?
You stick with your team, you
can choose a different theme,
just to be clear.
All right.
AUDIENCE: 10 minutes?
PHILLIP TAN: We have 10
minutes to figure out
who you want to
work with and what
your initial idea that you want
to work with, so go for it.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
And your team was six, right?
Cool.
You used the computer
control, so it
was really voice-activated.
It just didn't work.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: How many
of you have seen me
give this presentation before?
OK.
How many of you are
thinking does Phillip
give his presentation
every class?
Correctarino.
I do.
[LAUGHTER]
So I apologize to everyone
who's seen this presentation.
Maybe there's one or two
little points in here
that you might not
have seen before.
But for the most
part, it is the same,
because it is the
fundamental skill
that we try to teach in every
single game design class,
because it is basically
the first skill that you're
going to need to be
able to figure out
whether an idea works.
How many of you have made
prototypes in any field,
say engineering,
software, whatever?
All right, why do
you make a prototype?
AUDIENCE: Because it's cheaper.
PHILLIP TAN:
Because it's cheaper
than making the real thing.
Sure.
I thought I saw
some hands up there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's faster than
making the whole thing.
PHILLIP TAN: It's faster
than making the whole thing.
Yeah.
But that kind of goes
hand in hand too, right?
Time is money.
AUDIENCE: Making drastic changes
is a lot cheaper on paper
than it is the built system.
PHILLIP TAN: Ah, OK.
All right.
You can sort figure out what's
broken and then make changes.
AUDIENCE: It shows
the proof of concept.
PHILLIP TAN: It shows
You can show it to
other people, and not
just prove it to yourself.
Right.
AUDIENCE: It's a lot easier
to experiment and make changes
that are necessary when
you're not committed
to something like [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: All right.
You can try a lot of
different ideas, right?
It's like, I'm not quite
sure which way I want to go,
so I'm going to try a lot
of different alternatives.
AUDIENCE: It helps you realize,
maybe, your flaws [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: Catch
the big problems that
are going to break your design.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: To move from 2D to 3D?
PHILLIP TAN: To
move from 2D to 3D?
You'll make a 2D
prototype, before taking it
into a more complex design.
All of those are
absolutely true.
You know, just for
the general sense
of why you want to do a
prototype at all is to get
feedback from other people.
And you get it early,
you get it cheap.
And of course, we talked
about making changes
early on in the process.
Usually, it costs
less money because you
haven't committed anything.
You haven't invested a whole lot
of resources in something just
to have to change it again.
If you're not quite sure which
direction you want your design
to go, you want to be able to
have lots of different ideas
on the table and actually
see how all of them
work in one way or another.
We talked about how
easy it is to be
able to change our ideas
when you're prototyping.
But also, it's easy to
discard a prototype.
It's easy to just say,
well, that was a bad idea,
because you haven't really
spent all that much time on it.
And in many ways,
that's something
you're going to need to
do in game design a lot.
You're going to pursue
some of these ideas, some
of these ideas that you've
already been discussing.
And you're going to start
prototyping it today.
And then you're going to say,
well, that was a bad idea
and shove the whole thing
off the table into a trash
can somewhere and start afresh,
because you've spent what?
An hour designing this thing?
It's not going to be
a whole lot of time.
And then you can learn
from that process
and build something new.
So that is very
good mindset to be
able to have in
early iterations,
that this thing
that you're making
is meant to be informative.
It's meant to teach you
something about this project
that you're working on, but it's
also meant to be disposable.
It's something that you do
not have to make look good,
or you don't have
to make it last.
You don't have to
make it perfect.
You are just trying
to learn something
through the process
of prototyping.
Now, when you're
making games, this
is what you're
trying to figure out.
You're trying to find the fun.
And we've talked about
games being a series
of interesting choices.
And when you're prototyping,
what you are trying to do
is you are trying to identify
what are those few game
mechanics that are going
to be able to sustain
the interest of your players
over a significant amount
of time.
So the nice thing
about prototyping
when you're, say, trying to
design a computer game using
paper materials or
something is that you
have to define those mechanics
down to the very purest form.
So for instance,
I could say, oh,
this is going to be a
game about space aliens.
And you're going to
run around shooting
different kinds of weapons and
occasionally throwing grenades
and taking cover.
And you get to fly ships
and drive things around.
But what I can do when I'm
prototyping is that, all right,
I'm going to make a
game where you come out
and take a few potshots,
go under cover,
wait for your [? shoots ?]
to recharge, throw a grenade,
wait for [? shoots ?]
to recharge,
come out and take
a few potshots.
That's basically what game?
AUDIENCE: Halo.
PHILLIP TAN: That's
basically Halo.
That's the thing that you
do every 20 seconds in Halo
all the time.
And that's really
the thing that you
have to nail and get
absolutely right.
So when you are
making a prototype,
you can identify, oh,
this core little loop
is the thing that's interesting.
And if we can
actually get it right
and tuned perfectly in
[? additional ?] game, then
we know players are going
to do this over, and over,
and over again, and
it's gong to feel good.
So you're trying
to find that fun.
So you're going to focus on
the small handful of choices
that a player must make in
order to play your prototype.
And you model the system
with a few basic rules
that creates interesting
choices for the player.
Always ask a question
about your game.
Make sure it's falsifiable.
Anyone heard that term,
"falsifiable hypothesis"?
No?
Yep.
What's that mean?
AUDIENCE: Basically, it
means some kind of opinion
that can be proven wrong.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
You could say, well,
say the question is
that we think the players
are going to enjoy making
these kinds of decisions.
And the answer could
be, no, they don't.
You want that information.
It could be something like
this particular design
is going to save time, right?
It's going to be less
of a cognitive load.
Or it's going to be easier
for players to understand.
And it should be
that kind of question
that you ask when you're
making a prototype.
Your prototype should be
able to be designed in a way
where you can sit someone in
front of it, play through it,
and then tell you yes or no,
was that hypothesis true or not.
Now, physical prototyping,
paper prototyping,
doesn't give you insight
into everything that you
can achieve in a digital game.
It doesn't say, for
instance, tell you terribly
much about the sensory
experience of playing that game
or how feasible a certain
feature is going to be.
So you don't discover everything
through making a prototype,
but you do get a lot.
Now, the other thing that
a few people alluded to
is the ability
for your prototype
to communicate to other
people, especially
other people on your team.
So imagine getting into a
room full of developers.
All of you are game developers.
And you don't know what's in
each other's heads right now.
You maybe have come
down to a certain theme.
And all of you have
different versions
of that game floating
in your head somewhere.
Now, if you want to be able to
explain that to somebody else,
it can be near to impossible
to communicate that.
You can try doing it verbally.
You can try writing it down.
But all of those
methods don't really
compare very well to something
you can actually set somebody
in front and play.
So what you are
trying to do is you're
trying to give you own
team, to start with,
something solid to work from.
It may not necessarily be--
it will almost certainly not
be the idea that
you're going to end up
implementing in the long run.
But you're going to start
creating some sort of framework
for you to then say,
well, I didn't like that.
I should change that.
Or I really like that,
and we should try
to polish that a little bit.
So it's a communication tool.
And any kind of game
design definitely
benefits tremendously from early
stages of physical prototype,
because it forces you
to think through how
your game is going to work.
Every little detail about how
your rules worked, at least.
Maybe not how your
game looks, maybe not
what your input mechanism
is, but certainly
what are the decisions
you're asking for your player
and what are the consequences
of those decisions.
You have to define them.
You have to write
them down in rules
that your players, as
well as your design team,
actually understand.
And then they're
going to try it out.
And you're going
to see all kinds
of emergent little dynamics
pop up when all of these rules
are put together that you
didn't anticipate, and could
be really cool or could
completely break your game.
And you want to find that out.
I talked about
bringing in testers.
And as we keep
harping on this class,
and again, every single
class that I teach,
testing's incredibly important.
But the nice thing
about paper prototyping
is that you don't really
need special skills.
You need third grade arts
and crafts skills, really.
Maybe MIT math.
Sure.
But actual, we're
talking about using
markers and scissors and
kindergarten counters and dice.
And the nice thing about it
is that, as your team gets
larger and larger, everyone can
still contribute to the paper
prototype.
It could be an artist.
It could be a designer, a
producer, a [? quoter, ?]
a QA tester, even someone that
you just brought in for a day
to play your game,
can all contribute
to the design of the game,
because it can give you
feedback of, well, what if,
instead of rolling this dice,
I roll that dice.
Or what if the grid was
a little bit bigger?
What if my pieces were
a little bit larger
and took up more
space, for instance?
A paper prototype itself is not
just interactive in its play,
but is interactive
in the design.
You can just open up the
hood of your paper prototype
and change a rule.
Do not do that when
you're working with code.
In the middle of
a playtest, do not
change your code, for god sake.
But you can do that with
the paper prototype.
And many times, you
might want to do
that in the middle of a test.
It's like, you're
playing a game.
10 minutes into the game,
it's like, oh, my god,
this game is hurtling
downhill into a pit.
And you can see it.
And the player sees it.
And you know there's a problem.
You can just change
a rule and just say,
what if we did this
instead, mid-game even,
and then try it out.
And says, oh, that seemed to
maybe address the problem.
Then start the game
from the beginning
and see if it actually did.
But you can do that
with a paper prototype.
Paper prototypes,
in particular, are
very good at revealing
usability problems.
The simple issue of a
player has a decision,
knows what he or
she wants to do,
and has no idea how to
actually execute that.
It's like, does that mean
I roll first and then move,
or do I move first and
roll, which piece do I
move, things like that.
Paper prototypes
are very, very good
in sort of just
laying that bare.
Your team will see where
those problems are, as soon
as somebody who's
not part of your team
sits down and tries to play it.
Let's see.
Now, players do tend to
more readily give criticism
when they see something that's
very clearly incomplete, very
clearly something that
you're still working on.
And if you've got a
hand-drawn cardboard paper
prototype in front
of them, they know
you're right at the
beginning of this project.
They know that they can
tell you something about,
I really don't like how
this character looks.
And it's like, that's fine.
We spent two minutes
drawing that character.
We can completely redo that.
And they'll tell you that, if
it feels like you haven't spent
a whole lot of time in it.
And that's a useful trick,
by the way, if you are doing,
say, the digital version
of your games later on.
It can actually be
easier to get feedback
if you deliberately insert some
things that look incomplete,
a giant box that says Place
Order right there while you're
doing your testing,
just to get a little bit
more feedback from your testers,
so they feel, OK, yes, they're
working on this.
I can tell you that
character looks terrible.
And it's like, we
spent three days on it,
but you don't say that.
You don't say that
in front of them,
because you want that feedback.
But when they give you
feedback, you take everything
that they're telling you
with a grain of salt,
because, in the
paper prototype, it's
very, very easy for
a tester that says,
I don't like pieces
that are this color.
I want pieces that
are that color.
And it's, OK.
You could just make
the substitution.
But what you should do is you
should think back a little bit
and try to figure out
why they're giving you
this piece of feedback.
They may have a
personal preference,
and they think this is the
way how it should be executed.
But probably what
they're say is that they
have some sort of actual
problem with your game,
and that's the only solution
that they can think of.
So for instance,
why does this person
want to change the
color of the pieces
that they're moving around?
Is it because they're
having trouble
telling the pieces apart?
That may be the real problem.
And the solution may
not be change the pieces
to a different color, it
may be like change the piece
into a completely
different shape,
stick a little sticker on them.
On a computer, it's going to be
different kinds of solutions.
Vet every little
bit of information
that comes into you.
People can make
suggestions on how
you're going to
change your design,
but it's up to the team
to actually provide
some sort of unified
direction on where
you want the game to go.
So the feedback is valuable.
The solutions they're
providing may not
be the solutions
you want to use.
Any questions so far about
why we're doing prototyping?
No?
OK.
We'll have more questions later.
So here are the kinds of tools
that you're going to be using,
very large sheets of paper.
This is probably the smallest
sheet of paper-- well,
we're going to be using
index cards as well.
A lot of you have seen this
before in my other classes
as well.
This is a square grid on one
side, hex squared on another.
For spatial games,
you can use this.
But sometimes, it's
much better to start
with a blank sheet of paper.
So don't immediately
start designing grid games
just because we happen to
have sheets of gridded paper.
But we do want them to be
large, so that everyone
around the team can
actually see what you're
working on at the same time,
as well as the people playing
the game.
If you're going to be designing
something like an iPad game
or something like that,
don't use something that's
literally the size of the iPad.
Use something a
little bit larger,
so that everyone
around the table
can see what the tester
is doing while they're
testing your prototype
We use index cards for a
lot of different things,
writing down rules.
You can shuffle them and
use them as playing cards.
You can record data on them.
They're very disposable, more
accurately, very recyclable.
Please, please recycle
any paper material.
Dice, of course.
They can be tokens.
They can be used to help
keep track of stats.
But something that I've seen
a lot, that students like
to use a lot, is they
use two 10-sided dice
to keep track of a number
between zero to 99.
That's a really bad idea.
One brush of the hand, and
that variable is gone, right?
You can swap the tens and
the ones really easily.
It's like, was that 91 or 19?
I can't remember.
So if you want to
record variables,
just gram an index card and
just write down the variable.
And then, whenever
the variable changes,
cross it out right
in your variable.
It's much better for
you to use a dice either
as actual randomizers, or
you can use them sometimes
as tokens that move
around on the board.
Let's see.
What else?
Game bits, pieces
from other games
are wonderful, but sometimes
a little irritating because,
if you took them
out of the game box,
then you have to put them back
into the game box, otherwise,
you've just ruined
your copy of the game.
So I like using disposable
kindergarten counters a lot,
because I don't really care
about returning exactly
the same number I took out.
And there's usually
less assumption
about what a kindergarten
counter is supposed to be.
Is it a number?
Is it a person?
Whereas, if you use game bits,
that's kind of person-shaped,
[? meatball-shaped. ?]
Post-it glue and
notepads-- well, I
don't think we actually have
any Post-it glue right now,
but they're
basically glue sticks
that don't stick permanently.
So you put that on an index
card or on a piece of paper,
and suddenly, it
becomes a Post-it.
But what we do have are a
lot of Post-it note pads,
both big ones and small ones.
And these are useful for
you to simulate displays,
for instance, or variables and
information that a player is
supposed to have.
And you don't want that to go
flying off if somebody sneezes.
Of course-- oh, right.
I have a picture of some
Kindergarten counters
up there-- pencils, pens,
markers, scissors, tape,
just to be able to
hold things together,
write down information.
Something else about
Kindergarten counters.
We have a particular kind
of Kindergarten counter,
which is an interlocking cube.
You take it out?
PROFESSOR: Every year, we've--
PHILLIP TAN: Well,
it is possible
that we took them out because
they're very problematic.
Because once I give
you interlocking cubes,
you make games about
interlocking cubes.
It's like handing LEGOs.
And then, the first
thing everyone
thinks of is let's
make it a game
where you put things
together and assemble them.
AUDIENCE: Like
stacking counters.
PHILLIP TAN: Stacking counters.
AUDIENCE: So you
make games about--
PHILLIP TAN: Stacking.
Yeah.
The pieces that you end up
prototyping with sometimes
ends up shaping the
direction of your game.
And then, sometimes, if you
are dealing with a designer's
block, that can be helpful.
That gives you a path to follow.
But in many ways,
that's a distraction.
You start becoming constrained
by your tools, instead of
the idea that you're
trying to work with.
So if we managed to get rid
of the interlocking cubes,
that's awesome.
But if they're still in
there, by all means, use them.
But don't automatically
assume you
have to make a game
about interlocking cubes.
Now, don't forget to keep a
record of everything, including
all of the notes
that you've had.
Use your phone camera
doing the session.
At the end of your
project, make sure
that you try to
get them scanned,
photocopied in some way.
There are a lot of photocopy
machines around campus now.
There are actually scanners.
And you just put the
raw materials on top.
And instead of
generating a copy,
you can have them email a color
scan to your email account.
Those things are really useful
for your final assignment.
OK.
So those are the tools.
Who are the people
sitting around the table?
When you've actually
made a prototype, what
happens is-- I guess I got
some of my slides mixed up--
this usually happens at
the end of having designed
a workable prototype
is that there
is going to be a bunch of
people sitting around the table.
And each person has
a different role.
That's, of course, the
person who's actually
going to be playing
the game, preferably
somebody from a different
team or somebody who's
even outside of this class.
It could be one of us
instructors, for instance.
It could be one
of the OCW people.
And somebody in your team is
going to be a facilitator.
This is the person
who's going to present
the rules to the person
who's going to play,
you know, tell them that we're
looking for your feedback.
Make them comfortable.
Make sure that they
understand what they're
supposed to be doing and
basically making sure
that the session runs
according to script.
That person, or somebody else,
can also be the computer.
This is the person who is
actually making the prototype
work, updating variables,
moving the positions of pieces
on the board, revealing
new dialogue boxes,
or basically making the
board respond to what
the player decides to do.
And the computer is trying
to do all the computation
that your actual
computer will do,
if you're making a digital game.
The computer should not do
anything that a real computer
wouldn't.
So for instance, if somebody
doesn't understand a rule,
the computer person shouldn't
be correcting the player.
The facilitator could.
But sometimes, what I
find is really interesting
is that somebody thinks
a rule works differently.
I let them play through it.
And that becomes like
a different iteration
of the game.
And sometimes, it
turns out to be better.
Then you can run
through the iteration
with the correct rule.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the person
who's the computer
does have to make a choice
at that point of whether they
would let them play according
to what they think the rule is?
PHILLIP TAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Or what
the computer-- like
if it were a real
computer, it would just
think [INAUDIBLE] something
that doesn't work [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: And
it puts it in play.
And the computer says,
nothing happens, you know?
It's like you can
do that, right?
It's like if the person
really doesn't [INAUDIBLE].
But if you notice, say,
this person is clearly
playing a really
sub-optimal strategy,
just respond like
a computer will,
lead them to
[? that loose ?] condition
or whatever it is that happens.
Because in many ways,
that's how an actual player
is going to learn how to play
your game in the long run.
They're going to make
a lot of bad decisions.
The computer is
going to respond,
and then they're going to
learn from the mistakes
that they made and then
try it differently.
Let's see.
Something else that
the facilitator
can do while the game
is going on-- say,
the player is
actually playing-- is
to encourage the
player to think aloud.
So the person that you
brought in to play your game
is trying to
understand your game
and is just like
sitting there in silence
looking at the board.
And you don't know if they're
bored, confused, or really
into it.
So you ask them, what
are you thinking now?
And if they're saying,
what are all these pieces?
All right, then.
You know that they're confused.
The facilitator can
help, can say, all right,
let's start again,
and I'll explain
what all these pieces are.
They could be, ah, I've got
like five different strategies,
and I'm trying to figure out
which-- you know, I'm thinking,
maybe, if I move this here,
[? I move this out, ?] OK,
that person's into it, right?
That person's really thinking
hard about this problem.
Everybody else in your
team watching that board.
And this is the reason
why we have a big board.
As an observer, you
want to be able to see
what's going on in your game.
You want to be able to write
down the information in a note
book or on your laptop and try
to record whatever information.
Most importantly, look at
the face of the person who's
playing the game.
Again, that helps identify
whether they're confused
or whether they're
really into it
and trying to make
a tough decision,
or they're just bored.
Don't offer help to
the user, especially
if you're on the
development team
and you know all
about this game.
It can be a real temptation to
basically just tell the user,
this is what you want to do.
Don't do that.
Sit on your hands.
Bite your tongue.
It can be hard to
take notes when
you're sitting on your hands,
but, you know, take notes.
And the person who's
being the computer
and being the facilitator really
doesn't have the bandwidth.
Those people do not have
the bandwidth to take notes.
So someone has to be
officially designated
with the job of actually
taking notes and observing.
What we're going to be
doing is a Wizard of Oz test
for your games.
And that is someone's
playing the computer.
It's very constrained in
terms of communication
between the computer and the
person who's testing your game.
The rules are
usually pretty rigid.
And the nice thing
about it is that you
can do a pretty deep
analysis of a game.
You can make a game that sort of
goes through multiple decisions
into sort of long-term
consequences.
That's not
necessarily what we're
asking you to do for Project 1.
I'm just telling
you this because you
might want to do this
for Project 2, 3, or 4.
A Wizard of Oz test
allows you to really
do a deep dive into how a
particular feature works,
for instance.
And since it's a human
simulating the back end,
simulating the
computing, you can
be very high-fidelity
with very little cost.
That's not, again, we're
asking you to do for Project 1.
We're asking you to do a
low-fidelity prototype.
And we'll go into a little bit
more detail about what that is.
Very important.
Don't let the player know
what the computer is thinking.
The computer only
displays information.
You do not reveal
how the computer
is coming to those conclusions.
There are a couple of
other kinds of prototypes
that you could design.
I'm going to run through them
very quickly, because that's
not what happens in this class.
Player versus player, what
you'd expect in a board
game or a card game situation.
We have a class just for that.
And you can make cooperative
games, competitive games.
You can make games
where everybody
has the same role, a symmetric
game, or asymmetric game where
everyone has different roles.
The problem about
that is that there's
a lot of loose
miscommunication happening
between the people who are
actually playing your game.
And they may decide
on a house rule
that was totally not
what you intended
or designed as developers.
And that turns
out to be the rule
that you end up playing with.
Again, what I like
to do is I like
to see them play
through that rule.
Then, at the end of the
game, I correct them,
and I have them play
through the rule
that I originally designed,
because sometimes,
the rule that they
came up with is better.
The facilitator, again,
helps to explain the rules
at the beginning of the game.
And then you kind of
just watch after that.
It's hard to get consistent
results across tests
when you're doing
a multiplayer game,
because it's very
hard to duplicate
exactly the same situation.
Whereas, you can do
that on a Wizard of Oz
test pretty easily.
But if you're making
a multiplayer game,
you have to do a
multiplayer test.
So this might actually
happen-- actually,
are we saying that you
can only do single player
games this semester?
I'm not quite sure
what the constraint is.
You can also do live
action, not for today.
But I actually enjoy
these where you actually
have predetermined rules that
are explained between the game.
And then you just
let real human beings
walk around and do stuff.
The problem with this is there's
a very limited communication
between people who are playing
a game or even the people who
are running the game, because
everyone's kind of physically
spread out.
But it can be really
useful for a game,
if your game is really
about a human being walking
through a space, such
like a stealth game
or something like that.
Yes, that's actually a
person in that U-Haul box.
All right.
So when you're actually
making your prototype,
here are the things
that you have
to make sure you do for
every single prototype.
Keep it hand-drawn, because
hand-drawing is fast.
You want to keep it
really, really sketchy
and look really sketchy
and rough, again,
because that actually gets you
feedback from the people who
are testing.
You make it look
too pretty, people
are going to hesitate
on commenting on how
your game looks, for instance.
Or they may actually
hesitate on commenting
on how your game works,
even though that may not
be the prettiest
part of the game,
because they can tell you spent
a lot of time on this game.
Again, you want it to be big.
Everyone needs to be able to see
what's going on during testing.
And just use one dark color,
if you can for your inks,
for your markers.
It needs to be
dark, high-contrast,
so that everyone
can read it easily.
You can use different
color cards, for instance,
to be able to tell this card
is a different kind of card
from that card, but
don't use multiple colors
on the same card.
That's just not
worth the effort.
And again, it gives
people the impression
that you spent a lot of
time on this prototype.
And even if you
have, you don't want
to give them that impression.
You write your rules on cards.
So keep track of your rules.
Eventually, you're going
to end up typing it down
on your laptop, because that'll
make it easier for you to turn
in your work for Project 1.
But while you're
working on a prototype,
try writing your
rules on the cards
instead, because that
allows you to do things
like rearrange the steps in
which certain rules operate.
It allows you to change
out a rule really easily,
while keeping the
old rule around.
And you can just swap
things in and you
can try things differently.
Every time you change a
rule, change the card.
If you are changing the number
of rules, instead of taking,
say, take three
steps every turn,
you say take two steps every
turn, just cross out the three
and write two in there.
Now, periodically take photos
with your phone cameras.
And always try to simplify.
Always try to get
down to the smallest
set of rules that is necessary
for you to test your idea.
Part of that is just
to speed up testing.
You're going to test
within your team
first, just to be able to see
whether this basic mechanism
works.
And eventually, you're going to
end up testing with each other.
And the simpler your
rules, the less time
it is to be able to
start a new playtest,
because there's less
for you to explain
to somebody else who's
never seen your game before.
So try to get your rules to
be as simple as possible.
Also, if you have too
many rules and something
breaks in your game,
it's sometimes harder
to figure out which
rule was the culprit.
If you have fewer rules, it's
usually more obvious for you
to spot.
Now, we talked about
iterative design a lot.
And this is basically
the loop that we're using
while we are paper prototyping.
You start with a question,
a falsifiable question,
a yes/no question.
And what is this prototype
going to achieve?
Maybe in this particular
case it's going to be,
does this theme that we picked
actually have randomness in it
that you can plan for?
Or is it the randomness
so random to the point
where you can't plan for it?
Or is it really just very
deterministic, and when
you play the game, you can
really tell, yeah, here's
the optimal solution?
You can look at
axiomatic design--
anyone heard of this term?
[? Mackee, ?] in particular,
uses this a lot--
which is, basically,
you establish axioms,
which are things that you
are taking to be true,
a baseline that
need to be fulfilled
by any workable design.
So it could be we assume
that this game needs
to have some sort
of random condition
that's generated that
changes during the game.
And we need the
player to identify
that this number is changing
and anticipate where
that number might end up going.
And if your prototype
fulfills both of them,
then you know that
prototype worked.
And you can build a lot
of different prototypes
that fulfill those
same two conditions.
That's another way to
start with a question.
And then you actually
start designing, grabbing
those pieces of paper, writing
out your rules on cards,
brainstorming on what
your game's all about.
But you want to do this
as quickly as possible.
The less time you
can spend talking
about this, the more
different kinds of ideas
you're going to be
able to run through.
And that's what we're trying
to do during a prototyping
process.
If you're ever in
a situation where
you've got two different
options, this might be better,
or this might be
better, or you're not
quite sure, it's
usually faster in paper
prototyping to just start making
both prototypes, you know?
All right, you do this
version, you do this version.
Generate the cards, play
through both of them.
And you'll get actual evidence,
actual playtesting evidence
on which idea seems
to work better.
After you design,
you play through it.
First within your
team, and then you
grab somebody from
some other team,
or one of the instructors.
And we'll sit down and we'll
play a game and see where
the strength in this design,
where are the weaknesses.
Whatever you design
within an hour
is going to be clunky and
broken and really, really not
quite where you want to be.
That's find.
Do a playtest with
that expectation
that there are going
to be problems.
And you'll get a
lot more information
out of that playtest than
you will working on your own.
And then you use
that information
to revise your design.
Make changes, and then you
repeat this entire process
again.
Either you amplify
it on the strengths,
you figure out what
your weaknesses are
and you make big changes.
So you repeat that.
And here are a couple of tricks
that can work, sometimes,
if you have trouble figuring
out what sort of changes
to make in your design.
Killing a rule, just
like taking a rule out
sometimes fixes problems more
than trying to fix the rule
itself.
A certain thing is
bogging down the game,
a certain thing
is too confusing.
Just does the game work if
you just take that rule out?
Sometimes it does.
You can make a resource
that's limited, unlimited,
or make an unlimited
resource limited,
limited health, unlimited
health, limited ammunition,
money.
Player interference is more
for multiplayer games where,
sometimes, if everybody is
playing their own little solo
game and they're not
interacting with each other,
you'd come up with ways to
mess up each other's plans.
That doesn't always apply
with single player games.
But if you've ever played a
game like a role playing game
where you can delay an enemy.
Has anyone seen
one of those where
you can like cast slow
or something on an enemy,
and then they can't attack you
for another turn or something.
That's player
interference, right?
Only the player that
you're interfering with
happens to be the computer.
What can you do to basically
get into somebody else's plan
and change it?
And the computer can
have those rules too.
Mess with the play order.
Mess with the order
of your rules.
Just try rearranging
the order of rules.
And sometimes by grouping
things into logical chunks,
it can make the game
easier to understand.
Instead of saying, first,
you decide whether you're
going to do this.
Then you decide whether
you're going to do this.
Then you're going to
decide whether to do this.
Maybe you just say, make two of
these three decisions, right?
And every turn, you get
two out of these three.
Make them any order you want.
That's a way that you
mess up play order.
If you're going to
change variables,
either multiply or
divide them by two.
There is not enough
granularity in the prototypes
that you're making today
to do like a 10% change
in a certain
variable and then be
able to detect whether that
change was the right change
or not.
That's not going
be obvious enough.
Do like big multiples
of two, of three,
to be able to see whether that's
the change that's necessary.
You can tune things
later when you
are preparing the project for
the playtest on Wednesday,
for instance.
But when you're in this class,
do things by big multiples.
If your game's
really, really, really
kind of getting bogged down
and taking too long to play,
try to get down to
the core set of rules,
the minimum set of
rules that's necessary
even just for your game to work.
Just for the game
to run at all, try
to figure out what that core
is, the minimum set of rules.
And then you add in
each rule, one by one.
Reconstruct your game.
That's one way to identify
where the main problems are
in your game because, as you
add the problematic rule,
things start to break.
And finally, be willing to
just throw away everything
that you generate in
the next hour, OK?
Anything that you
make in the next hour
might, in fact,
just be terrible.
And you're going to learn that.
And that's fine.
That's why we're
making prototypes,
so that they can be disposable.
That's how I started this talk.
So any questions before we
actually start making stuff?
Coming up with rules?
You're going to grab
pieces and create
some sort of a play
surface or cards
that people are
going to play with.
You don't need to put
anything on a board.
And before everybody runs
down and grabs things,
I guess we're going to go
back and remind people what
a low-fidelity prototype is.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: --terrible as
long as you're aware of it.
AUDIENCE: I thought I replaced
it with a stacking counter,
so I guess it didn't work.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
[? ANDREW GRANT: All right. ?]
So we just have a couple more
minutes left of class.
A couple of things to
remember before you leave.
Take pictures of all of
your brainstorming notes.
And keep your notes with you,
so take them away with you.
Make sure everyone on your
team can access those notes.
Make sure you know the email
addresses of the people
you're on your team with,
so you can talk them again.
And before you leave
the classroom today,
start up a document and
enter your change log.
So put in what
you designed today
and what problems you found
by the end of the day.
So I'm going to repeat
that one last time.
Before you leave class
today, start up a document,
open it up, and start up
your new design change log.
Put the date.
Put what you did
today, so a brief, two
or three-sentence description
of what you designed today
and what are the problems
you're facing now.
That'll be important to you
both for when you meet as a team
again to remember what
you did, but also later
on to have a full history of
everything that you've done.
OK?
One more thing.
Yes?
SARA VERRILLI: One more thing.
Tomorrow--
[? ANDREW GRANT: Wednesday. ?]
SARA VERRILLI:
Wednesday, rather, we
are going to have playtests.
We're going to be playtesting
all the prototypes.
So you need a playable prototype
for Wednesday, 3 o'clock.
[? ANDREW GRANT: And ?]
then we're starting
Wednesday's class off with
discussions about the gaming
tutorial, so bring
your problems,
bring your questions about the
engines that you were assigned.
And we'll talk about them.
All right.
See you Wednesday.